philadelphia eagles while we stay in the
nfc east introduce joe flacco today as
the backup quarterback unless he isn't
to jalen hurts here's flacco with his
mentality as he embarks on his latest
nfl assignment
joe there's been some questions about
just how you view kind of
uh mentoring a young quarterback um what
what is uh your take on that especially
right now as it applies to applies to
hertz and and uh you know have you kind
of evolved in that way over the course
of your career
right well listen i i think i've spoken
to it a little bit and just saying that
you know i'm here to do what's best for
our team and help us win football games
and the thing i've said so far is that
you know i think competition you know in
any room and on any team
is something that brings out the best
and you know that's really what i'm here
to do will you mentor jalen hurts and
help
well like i said i i think every every
quarterback room you know guys help each
other uh that's what we're here for
that's what the whole team does
um so
i'm gonna i'm gonna do my part and we're
gonna win a lot of football games and
part of that is getting in the qb room
grinding and and helping each other out
do you think you're going to have a
legitimate shot to compete for the
starting job here
i'm not even really looking at that at
that way at this point
you know like i said i really just want
to come in and you know your goal as a
football player is always to show people
you know around you that you can play
football and i don't care
what level of playing that is whether
you're the first string second string
third string guy on the team you still
want to prove to everybody on the
football team
that you can play football and that you
deserve a spot on this team in some
capacity and that's really what my job
is
you know there are typically two types
of backup quarterbacks number one there
is the guy who knows he's the backup is
there to support the starter and be
ready to go in the event the starter
gets injured or otherwise isn't
available then there's the backup who
has the burning desire to play and they
are pushing and they are competing and
you never know at what moment the backup
may become the starter the proverbial
most popular guy in town backup
quarterback typically behind a not very
good starter i think flacco falls into
this middle ground where he's not
conceding anything he's not wired to
concede anything and i think another
thing that makes him unique miles is the
fact that he is the rare former
franchise quarterback once upon a time
the highest paid player in football who
is hanging around the sport at a time
when most guys who once were
the guy would say
i'm not holding a clipboard for anybody
i'm the guy and my guess is the stuff
that flacco says about his role is the
most you could ever expect
a guy who's been
the guy a super bowl mvp not
accidentally in that slumdog millionaire
away like nick foles but a real super
bowl mvp as a starting quarterback
that's the most he's ever going to say
if he's a backup he's never going to
concede that he's the backup
okay the the one name that i would throw
sort of back at you would be alex smith
because alex smith was the guy but he
did not get as far as joe flacco did
he's not been the mvp but he was still a
number one overall pick right and alex
smith is this kind of person who not
only when he was still the starter in
kansas city said i'm taking patrick
mahomes under my wing and patrick
mahomes has praised him multiple times
about just how the the kind of care that
alex smith took in terms of helping uh
set patrick mahomes up for success but i
mean you heard it in washington with
heineke
so
i i just when i listen to joe flacco
it's almost like dude what's your deal
man like i understand what you're saying
and that yeah if you've been the guy and
you've been a super bowl mvp you don't
really want to hold a clipboard for
anybody but at the same time like
he didn't really bait out drew lock and
it's not like he was there to do more
than back up sam darnold in new york
with the jets what what makes him think
that you know he's gonna go to
philadelphia and all of a sudden he's
gonna be the guy and i don't really
think he's going to be the guy but why
can't he just say yes of course i'm
going to mentor jalen hurts because i
want us all to do better it's like that
word is just so verboten to him and he's
just afraid of it and he won't say it at
all it's like voldemort i don't really
get it
well and i and i like that i do think
that part of it is
even though guys are on the same team
there is an inherent degree of
competition
that happens among
teammates because
they all want to get on the field they
all want to be the guy and you know joe
flacco may not not be wired to take
someone under his wing he may be wired
to just lead by example you know and not
go out of his way to say my job is to be
essentially
an additional assistant coach
a quarterback assistant coach to jalen
hurts i'm here to do what i do
and if he pays attention he'll learn
some things but i'm not gonna stop and
explain it to him like he's five years
old and i think at a certain level joe
flacco would say if we really boiled
this down and had time to go back and
forth and and peel the onion and see why
he is this way i think at a certain
level it's disrespectful and it's
condescending to tell guys exactly what
they need to do they're in the nfl they
know what to do and they know what to do
to learn things in the nfl you watch and
you study and you pick things up and you
incorporate them into your game so i'm
not i just
i
i think i understand where joe flacco is
coming from and i don't think it's
malicious that that's just my that's my
take it uh
and i think the i think the eagles are
comfortable with that too they wouldn't
assigned him
well sure i i don't necessarily think
it's malicious either i just
to me it just strikes me is i don't know
just this weird awkward thing because
look we've all heard the report that
jeffrey lurie wants the eagles to do
everything that they can to support
jalen hurts as a starter and frankly if
you sign joe flacco to me that signals
that you want a backup quarterback it's
not it's not that you want somebody that
can really come in there and push to
become the starter so
i i guess i could be wrong about that
perception if then what happens is that
joe flacco comes in and he says well my
job is to show that i can still play
football and if you're a backup
quarterback then yeah you still need to
show that you can play football that's
for sure but i don't know it just
i i guess when you have something like
that mentorship and being a mentor and
accepting mentorship as a mentee it all
depe it all has to be genuine and it all
has to really reflect who you are as a
person and i think that this is not just
in football this is in life like you if
it's not genuine to you then you
probably shouldn't be going out there
and saying yeah like yes i'm gonna be a
mentor i'm gonna make sure that i do
everything i can to help him become the
best quarterback he can be
if that's not who you are then it's not
who you are and i can't blame joe flacco
if it's not who he is
but at the same time i just i don't know
it's a weird thing to me where he's just
he won't use the word mentorship and he
won't just say yes i'm going to help
jalen hurts
and i agree with what you're saying and
i do think it comes down to personal
style and it's well documented that this
is the way joe flacco is and it may be
that it does work to the advantage of
the starter because you do have the
presence of someone there who isn't
conceding anything who isn't acting like
he's the old-timer a coined term this
week on pft live that has gotten pete
demolitis on my bad side so he keeps
using it and sims especially but uh i i
just think it comes down to personal
style you know to give you an example i
mean we've now got five different people
that work
with me at pft i don't get in anyone's
face and say
hey we're going to have a session today
and i'm going to tell you all the things
you need to do i trust people to figure
out what they need to do and i try to
set an example that they can learn and
if there are questions i will answer
them but i trust for example that you
know what you're doing you wouldn't have
the job if you didn't know what you're
doing you don't need me bugging you
saying you should do this and you should
do this and hey let me tell you a story
about the time i did this
i i got sausage to make you got sausage
to make we're both making sausage and if
you learn something about my sausage
making process along the way that's good
maybe and again everybody's different in
how they mentor and some people choose
to do it by setting the example and
maybe that's what flacco is doing and
maybe he just doesn't articulate it well
or maybe
people pull out you know
random quotes that really don't look
good they don't like some of the things
he says if you isolate and it's not
taking it out of context it's all part
of a
continuous
monologue from him
it's not unfair to isolate it and focus
on it but some of the isolated comments
it's like yeah the guy's being kind of a
jerk but i think i understand
where he's coming from and i don't have
a problem with it that's i guess that's
the best i can do with it
it just sounds like you identify with
him old timer
thank you so much i'm great
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports